bonjour eric zemmour et bonne année
merci bonne année à tous cette fois ça y
est le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne
et vous affirmer que les grands gagnants
du break site ce sont eux les anglais
pourquoi on peut le dire comme ça je je
je je dirais pas vainqueurs ou vaincus
je dirais effectivement mais là où vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est que je
pense que la commission de bruxelles a
été dépassé par elle même je vais
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi
en fait depuis l'arrivée des anglais en
1973 dans l'union dans le marché commun
à l'époque on disait les anglais ne se
sont jamais départi du des mêmes
principes c'est à dire il son tour le
projet économique c'est-à-dire le grand
marché et le commerce libre sans droits
de douane etc et ils sont contre le
projet politique de l'heure une
construction plus ou moins fédéral du
d'une grands empires européens qui
rassemblerait le continent est en fait
le break site si on le voit sous cet
angle là ce n'est que la continuation
par d'autres moyens du même projet c'est
à dire on veut toujours l'économie mais
on veut vraiment pas du politique à dire
des directives de bruxelles de la
commission d arrêt de la cour de justice
des d12 de la liberté des personnes avec
les travailleurs détachés tout ça même
si ils n'ont jamais ratifié schengen
voyez c'est toujours la même discussion
et je constate alors en face évidemment
souvenez-vous des débuts la négociation
la commission de bruxelles est la baie
avec michel barnier le projet exactement
inverse c'est à dire on disait aux
anglais vous ne pourrez accéder aux
grands marchés européens pour commercer
librement que si vous acceptez les
arrêts de la cour européenne de justice
et tout là est tout le droit européen
c'était ça le débat au départ en fait
d'après vous les négociateurs de
bruxelles sont les victimes d'une
idéologie qu'il aura été un stylet par
les anglais bas
c'est ça le paradoxe si vous voulez on a
eu on sait il ya eu des dizaines de
livres là dessus on sait qu'il ya eu
deux époques de l'europe il ya eu le
temps du marché commun que je dirai à la
française avec le tarif extérieur commun
donc vous voyez là la fameuse forteresse
europe comme disaient les américains
c'est à dire on fait du marché ont en
commerce entre nous mais on a un tarif
extérieur commun pour l'ebre et puis
après à partir des années 80 l'idéologie
libre-échangiste a gagné enseignée par
les anglais c'est pour ça que
j'ironisais et il la commission de
bruxelles et l'europe est devenue le
vraiment le comment dire l'agent de la
mondialisation le 1 le cheval de troie
de la mondialisation multipliant les
accords de libre échange et c'est le
résultat c'est que de la négociation
c'est que les anglais pourront accéder
aux grands marchés européens sans droits
de douane
donc ils pourront continuer à commercer
comme avant avec tous les pays européens
mais en revanche il ne se ne se
soumettront pas au droit européen à la
cour de justice et aux normes
européennes donc oui comme vous didier
au début ses victoires sur toute la
ligne des onglets le reste c'est des
nuances et des nécessaires des compromis
on dit qu'il faut pas trop dériver par
rapport à ces normes qu'on va se revoir
et c'est briller tout ça c'est normal
mais dans les grands principes c'est
quand même la grande bretagne qui a
gagné et pour une raison simple c'est
que c'est comme si la commission de
bruxelles négocier avec elle même
puisque la grande bretagne c'est sa mère
puisque c'est celle qui l'a qui lui a
enseigné cette idéologie libre
échangiste et d'ailleurs dans la foulée
les anglais ont repli aurait pitt ont
répliqué que ce pas comment on peut dire
la plupart des accords de libre échange
à 77 signé par l'union européenne avec
les autres pays on nous a bassiné avec
la force de négociation de la commission
de bruxelles vous souvenez c'est du vent
vous ne croyez pas plus mais c'est du
vent dans les faits puisque les anglais
tout seul ont obtenu la même chose que
ce que l'union européenne a obtenu
vous voyez bien
et du vent ça ça n'existe pas mais c'est
logique c'est même pas partial ce que je
dis vous comprenez dans un monde
protectionnistes il est très utile
d'être dans une zone de libre-échange
puisqu'on commerce à l'intérieur et
c'est très bien oui mais dans une dans
un monde de libre échange parce que
c'est ça la mondialisation il ya plus de
droits de douane nulle part il ya des
normes différentes il ya des voiliers il
ya détaillé des il ya des accords
techniques oui mais il ya plus de droits
de douane
c'est bien le principe même de la
mondialisation c'est ce qui explique les
chaînes de fameuse chaîne de valeur et
ses ballades les produits pour faire une
voiture on vous la balade dure monde
entier si on peut l'appeler balader dans
le monde entier ces cas pas de droits de
douane vous êtes d'accord avec moi
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben ça
n'a plus aucun intérêt dans une zone de
libre échange et donc il ne reste que
les inconvénients
c'est à dire les pertes de souveraineté
merci eric zemmour